[Music]
[Music] [Music] [Music
] [
Music] [Music] [Music
] [Music] [Music] [Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Music] [Applause]
[Music]
[Applause  ]
[Applause]
[Music] [Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music
]
[Applause]
[Music]
[  Applause]
[Applause] [Music] [
Music] [Music] [Applause] [Music
]
[Applause] [Music] [Music] [Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Music
]
[Music]
[Music] [Music] [
Music] [
Music] [Music
]
[Applause] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music
] [Music] [Music]
[
Music]
[Music  ]
[Music]
[Music] [
Music]
[Applause] [Music] [Applause] [
Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Applause] [Music] [
Applause] [
Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[  Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Music] [Music
] [Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Applause] [Music
Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Music] [
Music] [Music] [
Music] [Music
] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Applause] [Music
]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause  ]
[Applause]
the Word of God
reading from the book of the prophet
thus speaks him who is higher
than all him in eternal pain
and in
[Music]
the means
humbled in his bed to animate
to animate the hearts of those  who was
sent
because I will not always be his
process nor ceaselessly
[Music]
because of his products
I was irritated against my people I
took him in my detour
he followed
but I will cure him I will lead him I
the Congolese
[Music]
and on their lips I will pray
peace to the one who is far and to the one
who is near
says the Lord yes
this people I will heal them
[Music]
Lord at this level of
[Applause  ]
[Music]
at the house of the Lord
[Applause] [Music] [
Music] [Music] [Music]
happiness [Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music] [Music]
[Applause] [Music] [Music
] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music
]
[Music]
the Lord be with you
[Applause]
[Music]
It was after the death of Jesus
the evening came on that first day of the
week when the doors of the place where
the decisive ones were were
locked by 30 of Jesus
going and there he was in the middle of
he  send them
[Music]
filled with joy seeing the Lord
Jesus their life these days the earth
be with
the hotel [
Music]
I too am sending you
and
he breathes on them and they have them
receive the Holy Spirit
at  who you remit these sins it will be
remitted
to whom you maintain these sins
they will be now
please stand up a
long time
thank you
for being there
the Gospel has just told us that
the joy of disciples was also great
in our choice of steps and that this joy in
seeing the Lord
in this atmosphere of
destructive seal the Risen One is for
support and that  does that give them
first three months peace
it's a greeting but it's more
than a greeting
we expect because peace it was
announced by the angels and the night of
Bethlehem this scene that Jesus
also promised she is now for the
first time solemnly given to the
disciples the peace of Jesus which is
also given to us in every mass and
Pascal she comes with the resurrection
because the Lord
is to reconcile the world with the father he
had to test you our  loneliness and
our abandonment our children
embracing bridging the distances that
separate us from life and hope
maintaining the distances between heaven
and earth
maintaining
peace Jesus is given to the disciple
[Music] [
Music]
[Music]
punish like him  there was a knot of
guilt frustration sadness fear
and well while
in the hearts of the disciples there were
ruins Jesus proclaims peace as they
feel death knot he
announces life in  other words
the call to Jesus comes when everything
seems infinite for them at the most
unexpected and unexpected moment when there is no
glimmer of peace so does the Lord he
amazes us he shakes his hand when we
are about to sink  a relief
when we hit rock bottom brothers and
sisters with Jesus evil never wins
he never has the last word he is
the Christ who is our peace
and his peace and victorious
that is why we who belong to
Jesus we can't let
sadness get the better of us we
can't let resignation and
fatalism take hold if we breathe
this atmosphere around us that
isn't so for us in a world
discouraged by violence  and war
Christians must do like Jesus
he insistently repeated to the disciples
peace be with you and we are
called to do our and tell the world
it is a name it is unexpected and
prophetic
[Music]
but we ask  us how to keep
in cultivating the peace of Jesus himself has
indicated to us to ensure
three sources to continue to cultivate
them they are forgiveness the community and the
mission let
us see the first source the forgiveness
Jesus of the conscious to whom you will remit
these sins they will be  handed over however
surrendered to the apostles the power to
forgive and forgives them not with
words but with a gesture the first
that the Risen One accomplished sales
the Gospel says he shows them to his hand
and his side that is to say to whom theirs
shows his wounds he will have he offers them
because we forgive ourselves
wounds
when the wounds are suffered do
not leave scars in but
become the place where to make room
for others their weakness the fragilities
then become opportunities and
forgiveness becomes the  path of peace it
is not about leaving everything behind
as if nothing had happened but about opening
your heart to others with love this is
what Jesus does in the face of the misery of those
who have denied him  abandoned he shows his
wounds and opens the source of
Mercy one does not use many
words but he opens his wounded heart wide
to tell us that he is always wounded
with love for us
[Music] [Music] [
Music]
[Music  ]
[Music]
when guilt sadness
oppresses us when things are not going
well we know how to look to the
wounds of Jesus ready to forgive us
with his infinite wounded love he knows
your wounds he knows the wounds
your country of your  people of your land these
are wounds that burn
continually infected with hatred and
violence while the remedy of
justice and the balm of hope
never seems to have arrived
brother sister jesus suffers with you he
sees the wounds you carry within  you
and desires to console and heal you by
presenting his wounded heart to you God repeats to
your heart the words he spoke
today through the prophet Isaiah I will
heal him I will lead him I will shower him
with consolation
together today we believe  that there
is always with Jesus the possibility
of being forgiven and starting over and
also finding the strength to forgive
oneself, others and history
this is what Christ wants to give back to us
with his forgiveness for us  give peace
and the courage to forgive in turn
the courage to accomplish a great
amnesty of the heart
as it is good for us to purify our
hearts from the wrath of remorse from all
resentment and from all grounds may well
love this day be  a time of grace
to welcome and live forgiveness Jesus
which is an opportunity for you who carry
a heavy burden in your heart that you
need to get rid of to
start breathing again and which is a
favorable moment for you who claimed to be a
Christian  in this country and who commits
violence to you the Lord says lay down
your arms embrace mercy and to
all the oppressed wounded of his people
he says do not be afraid to put your
wounds in mine your wounds
in my wounds let's do it  brother and sister
do not be afraid to take the crucifix out of
your school and out of your pockets to take it
in your hands and wear it on your
heart to share your wounds with
those of Jesus back home
take the crucifix you have  and
embrace it let's
give Christ the possibility of
healing our hearts
let's throw into him the past all the fears
all the anxieties like these beautiful
to open the doors of the heart and that of
the house to undermined and why not
write in your rooms on your
clothes outside your homes
this word
peace to
exhibit you there and will be a prophecy to the
land a blessing from the Lord on what
you will meet
peace to you let us be forgiven by
God and forgive us one another
[  Music]
so
anotolto not in the general community
of discussions
it takes
the career
and it's over
the community
Jesus risen does not address the
disciples individually but he
meets together he speaks to them more
real and gives his peace to the first
community he  there is no Christianity
and without community just as there is no
operating without brotherhood but
as a community or walk or go to
find peace let
's look again at the disciples before
Easter he followed Jesus but he
still reasoned  in a too
human way they hope to conquering Messi
who would have driven out the enemies who would have
accomplished products i miracles
which would have increased their prestige and
their resources but this world desires
left them empty-handed worse they
took away from the community the peace in
generating discussions and
oppositions for us too there is this
risk of being together but moving forward alone
by seeking in society but also
in the church the power the career the
ambitions but in this way we follow
our own and me instead  of the true God
he ends up like disciples
locked up at home empty of hope and
filled with fear and disillusionment but
here he is able he finds the way to
peace thanks to Jesus who breathes on
them and says
receive the Holy Spirit thanks to the Spirit
Holy he is will consider more what
divides them but what unites them they will
go into the world no longer for
themselves but for others not
to have visibility but to
give hope not to
gain approval  but to spend
their lives with joy for the Lord and
for others
[Music]
and brotherhood the evening
for us is to follow the spirit of the
world rather than that of Christ and what
is the way not to fall into the
traps of  power and money not to
give in to divisions to the flatteries
of careerism that gnaws at the community
to the false illusions of pleasure and of
the library that contains within itself the
Lord suggests them to us again through
the intermediary of the prophesy
saying  I am with who is crushed
humiliated in his spirit to animate
the spirit of humiliate to animate the
heart of what we have crushed
the means is to share with the
poor here is the best antidote is
against the temptation to divide us and
to become worldly have the courage to
look at the poor and to listen to them
because they are members of our school
community and not strangers to be
removed from our sight and our
unconsciousness
to open another heart to others instead of
locking it up on  our problems or
our vanities we
start from the poor and we
will discover that we all share
an interior poverty that we
all need the Spirit of God to
free us from the spirit of the world that
the humility and greatness of the Christian and
brotherhood its true wealth believe
in community and with the help of the
gods let us build a church empty of
worldly spirit but filled with the Holy Spirit free
from all wealth for oneself and full
of brotherly love
[Music]
finally we  let's come to the third
source of peace the mission Jesus says
to the disciples just as the Father
sent me too I send you
he sends us like the pearlant sent
and how did the Father send him into
the world
he sent to serve and give his life
for humanity to show his
mercy for everyone to seek
those who are far away in a word he sent
for all
not only for the just but
in this sense the words détailir
resound to  new peace peace to those
who are far away and to those who are near
says the Lord to those who are far away
first and to the loved ones not
only to ours but to all brothers
and sisters we are called to be
missionaries of  peace and it
will give us peace it is a choice it is to
make peace a place in our
hearts for all it is to believe that
ethnic, regional,
social and religious differences come after
and are not obstacles to believe that
the  others are brothers and sisters
members of the same human community
to believe that all are recipients of the
peace brought to the world by Jesus
is to believe that we Christians
are called to collaborate with all
to break the circle of violence to be
dismantled  the conspiracies of hatred yes
the Christians sent by Christ are
called by definition to be the
conscience of the peace of the world not
only of the critical consciences but
especially of the witnesses of love not those
who claim their own right but to
those of the  gospel of
brotherhood love and forgiveness not
those who seek their own interests but
missionaries of the crazy love that
God has for every human being
Jesus says today to every family community
ethnic group neighborhood
city of this great  country peace be with
you peace be with you that these
words of our Lord
resound in all that in silence
feeling that it is addressed to us and
choose to be witnesses of the forgiveness
of the actors in the community of
people in mission  to operate in the
world
[Applause]
and urges us to say to the Lord remove
all iniquities
[Music]
[Music] [
Music] [Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Music] [Music] [
Music]
[Music]
[  Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Music] [Music
] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music
]
[Music]
because of the sacrifice of your son it is
this Christ who is built  inhabit our
hearts and who does not prevent being drowned in
the deep and silent water of your
mercy
[Music] may
the peace of the Lord always be
with you
brothers and sisters in the charity of
Christ give you peace
[Music]
[Music  ]
for the Church
that she may always be at the service of the
weakest and the poorest that she
announces the good news to the periphery
to all men praying to the
Lord
[Music] [
Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[  Applause]
for the Holy Fathers Francis
may he always be supported by the power
of the Holy Spirit to strengthen the faith
and charity of the faithful and consolidate
the peace of Christ on earth let us pray to the
Lord
[Music]
[Applause]
[  Music]
[Music] [Music] [
Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Music] [Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Music
] [Music
] [
Music]
Samoura
Gan
[Music]
[  Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Lord the prayers that dispite
the Lord
[Music] [Music] [Music
] [Music] [Music] [Music
]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music  ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Music]
[Music] [Music] [Music
] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music
]
[Music]
[  Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
be pleasing to God the Almighty Father the
Lord receive from your hands his
sacrifices to the praise and glory
salmon for our good and that of the
whole Church let us
pray to the Lord
we celebrate Lord under the signs
of the sacraments the sacrifice of salvation
offered by your son the king of peace
we pray since this offering
is a sign of peace and unity
that it contributes to strengthening
harmony between all children
through Christ  our Lord
[Music]
the Lord be with you
[Applause]
our heart
[Music]
to the Lord our God
truly holy father it is just and
good for your glory and our salvation to offer
you our action of  grace and
always and entouilles by your
beloved Son Jesus the Christ
it is with word by which you created all
things it is him which you sent to us
as Redeemer and Savior God made
man conceived of the Holy Spirit born of the
Virgin Mary to fulfill
your will to the end and gather a
holy people who belong to you, the mayor is stretched
at the hour of his passion in order to
break death and manifest the
resurrection that is why with the
angels and all  the saints we feel your
glory and with one voice we
proclaim
[Music]
[Applause] [
Music] [
Music]
you are holy Lord our God your
only son our Lord Jesus Christ is
your spirit the Paraclete S1 you  O Holy
Almighty God we beg
hear us
look at this bread look at his wines
look at them sanctify them that the
Holy Spirit descends from on his offerings that
we present to you what becomes for
us the Body and Blood of our
Lord Jesus the  Christ
the same night he delivered he took
bread he owes you he gave you thanks
will go more bread and gave it to his
disciples he says
take and eat without all
these is my body delivered for you
tomorrow after the meal he  took the cup
he
gave you thanks he gave to his
disciples he said
take and drink of it all for this is the
cup of pieces the blood of the
new and eternal Covenant which will be shed
for you and for the multitude in
remission of your sins  do this in
memory of me
[Music]
[Laughs]
Lord our God we remember
the death and resurrection of your
Son we offer you the bread of life
we ​​offer the cup of salvation we
give you thanks  for you have chosen us to
stand before you to
serve you
Lord God of mercy behold
we are going to eat the body of Christ
we are going to see the blood of Christ we
ask you have mercy send us
your Spirit upon us who gather us together
may we be in
Lord may your Spirit bring us together
may we be
one lord
come from your Church
and spread them throughout the world
may all Christians love each other as you
loved us remember
our part Francis
remember  our bishop Frida
remember what verifies from Le
Mans on the successful fair of the apostles
also remember those who
govern our nation
that they live in justice and
holiness
Lord remember
all
Lord
our brothers and sisters  who died in
the hope of being resurrected
or saved
remember
all the men and women who
have left this earth and whose
uprightness of heart you know remember
to
receive the
see your face Lord
[Music]
we beg you
remember us all
receive us one day with you
where the Blessed Virgin
Mary Mother of God is
with Saint Joseph her husband
the contributions and all that you love
and  who loves you forever may
we all be with you
to praise and glorify you
through your son Jesus Christ our
Lord
through him with him and in him
[Music]
in unity
of spirit
[Music]
for heaven  blue
united in the same spirit we can
confidently say the prayer we have
received from the Savior
our Father who is
thy name hallowed be thy kingdom
come the will be done on
earth as it is in heaven give
us this day  today our daily bread
forgive us our trespasses as we
also forgive those who
trespass against us and do not let us enter into
temptation but I deliver us said evil
deliver us from all evil Lord and
give peace to our
sustained time  by your mercy we will be
freed from all sins safe from all
your proofs we who wait for these to
realize this blessed hope
the coming of Jesus Christ our
Savior
[Music]
power and glory for ever and
ever
[Music  ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause] [Music] [
Music] [Music] [Music]
[Laughter] [
Music]
[Music]
here is the lamb of the gods here
is he who takes away the sins of the
happy world  invited to the wedding feast
of the Lamb
Lord I am not worthy to
receive you but just say a word
and I am
[Music]
[Music] [
Music] [
Applause] [Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause] [Music] [
Music] [Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Music] [Applause] [Music
] [
Applause] [Music]
[Music]
[Music  ]
[Music] [Music] [
Music] [
Music] [Music] [Music
] [Music] [
Applause] [Music] [
Laughter] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music
]
[Music]
[  Music]
[Applause] [
Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [
Music]
[Music]
of your only son we make
fruitful between us the peace that he
himself has  left him who lives behind that
the circle of sex
[Music]
[Applause]
very simple
it is with different
and gratitude
that I greet the presence of Your
Holiness in Kinshasa capital of the
Democratic Republic of Congo our
country
on behalf of  the church these families of God
who have come to pray with you and in the name of all the
Congolese people I would like to
express to you with all my heart
for this beautiful and great mass that
you have just presided over my
very simple gratitude
to the Democratic Republic of the Congo that
you are visiting in  this moment
is a
potentially very rich country
its
essentially young population
is predominantly Christian, of which more than
40%
of Catholics
these Congolese people are today
confronted with a multifaceted crisis
armed conflicts
particularly in the east of the country
economic crisis and social misery
yes
very nice
the people who welcome you today
and who are there in front of you
it is a people who suffer in
body and soul
[Applause]
despite this unjust suffering
the Congolese
nevertheless remain a confident people and
full of hope
here  why the comforting presence
of Your Holiness at the bedside of this suffering people
is a real encouragement
your very simple visit
also comes during an election year
which is often a source of
social and political tension in our country
[Music]
with the message
that you  brought on the theme
all
reconciled in Jesus Christ
and confident in your prayers
we hope to see free elections held in our
country
transparent
inclusive and peaceful
[Applause]
to end
very nice
thank you for being there for us
for each and  each of us
for our people who are suffering
thank you for your message
thank you for your homily of comfort
which confirms us in our faith
I nourish the hope that it is from the
charism that you have just presided will
consecrate us more to Christ in whom
we all are  reconciled
while I bless the Lord for these
moments of grace
I entrust the continuation of your
apostolic journey in the Democratic Republic
of Congo and South Sudan to
the intercession of the Virgin Mary Our
Lady of Congo I thank you
[Applause]
to your  name in Congo
the gift of his holy summer to our
national community it is a chalice
of great values ​​thank you
[Applause]
the Lord be with you
and in the names of the Lord
God Almighty bless us
the breads the sons the Holy Spirit
in the peace of Christ
[Music] [
Music]
[Laughter]
[Music] [
Music]
[Music]
thank you my
[Music] [
Music]
[Music]
in a bed